[Música]
cuántas veces nos hemos preguntado por
qué mi pareja me cuenta porque mi amigo
no valora mi amistad porque en el
trabajo no me toman en cuenta
yo creo que eso nos ha pasado a todos
son premisas y preguntas que muchas
veces nos hacen ruido pero que no
tomamos en cuenta
qué pasa siempre proyectamos en lo de
afuera en lugar de echarnos un clavado
sucede lo siguiente
como seres humanos nacemos nos crían
dentro de una familia nos dan valores
nos dan una serie
enseñanzas nos mandan a la escuela nos
enseñan a hablar nos enseñan a escribir
a colorear
vamos creciendo
nos vamos a primaria la secundaria y
tomamos muchas materias que en muchas
ocasiones
pues no sé ustedes pero yo sigo
esperando el momento indicado para usar
la fórmula al cuadrado del binomio
perfecto
de verdad para mí fue innecesario yo
hubiera preferido que me enseñaran a
gestionar mis emociones que me enseñaran
a valorarme que me enseñaran
administración económica administración
de mis recursos personales
agradezco siempre lo legado en mi núcleo
familiar que en muchas ocasiones viene
desde mis ancestros
y que se van repitiendo en automático
porque pues así ha sido siempre cuántos
de nosotros nos cuestionamos esto me
sirve esto es aplicable para mí
me pudieron haber enseñado a ser
responsable pero si eso hoy me ocasiona
un estrés ya no es saludable para mí y
no por eso está mal
imaginemos que papá y mamá junto con sus
padres cada uno
nos regalaron un costal lleno de monedas
a esas monedas les vamos a hablar a
poner nombre valores principios
obligaciones responsabilidades
no sé a cuántos de ustedes pero les
comparto una experiencia que tuve hace
cuatro años
jocelyn moría por ser la hija perfecta
la mamá perfecta la esposa perfecta la
trabajadora responsable y eso únicamente
me llevó a una crisis de salud que me
llevó al hospital por dos días
salgo de ahí con una lumbociatalgia
impresionante en donde únicamente me
estaban dando coctelito vacilador para
dormirme el malestar pero realmente no
me estaban atacando lo esencial que eran
los sentimientos que yo cargaba
conocí a una persona marcó mi vida
definitivamente
y esa persona me enseñó que no siempre
tenemos la obligación de cumplir los
patrones y las estructuras que se nos
han dado y que no por eso dejamos de ser
buenos hijos buenos padres o buenos
ejemplos
a que voy con todo esto
si yo sé lo que quiero
si yo
a dónde voy
si yo me amo y me respeto soy fiel a mis
creencias a mis convicciones
automáticamente voy a generar eso en el
otro
yo no voy a esperar a que otra persona
venga a hacerme fiel
si yo no me estoy dando un lugar
últimamente por situación de pandemia se
ha desarrollado mucho la educación
emocional
pero cuántas personas realmente
aplicamos lo que compartimos en redes
sociales
y tiene mucho que ver eso
si cuando uno es coherente congruente
con lo que dice piensa y hace
automáticamente la energía fluye de una
manera impresionante entonces ahí yo soy
consciente de que otro no va a venir a
suplir me otro no va a venir a decirme
lo que tengo que hacer y no por eso voy
a dejar de ser una mala persona siempre
con límites sanos a partir de ese
momento yo aprendí a decir no
por mis razones no por que fueran a
pensar o que fueran a decirme sí
esto conlleva a lo siguiente
cuándo
nosotros como papás la mayoría que lo
somos entramos como en cierto conflicto
soy ejemplo
pero una cosa es lo que yo enseño y otra
cosa es lo que yo digo
es bien importante conocernos
quién soy a dónde voy lo que estoy
haciendo me está llevando a lo que
quiero lograr
estamos viviendo una etapa de evolución
en todo sentido nos tocó la evolución
tecnológica nos tocó la evolución
educativa estamos ahora tiene otro mundo
ya las clases son virtuales yo creo que
es momento de tomar cada uno su acción
de tomar cada uno su responsabilidad
emocional y decir quiero esto y en el
momento en que yo lo quiero me respeto
me acepto me amo
y el otro vez era mi espejo y me
reflejara lo mismo
qué les parece la idea
se dice fácil eso es un trabajo diario
constante pero sobre todo de mucha
conciencia y mucho amor porque cuando
uno realiza lo que sea así sea la comida
así sea el aseo o su trabajo con amor
eso mismo se refleja en todo nuestro
nuestro entorno
muchísimas gracias muy agradecida y
emocionada por formar parte de télex
evolución
[Aplausos]